um as a comedian
and a comedienne
uh uh let's get let's have that let's
have that conversation do that i don't
know
has two comedians here there you go um
what the hell happened is something like
is that something that is just
completely off-limits someone getting up
from the crowd no matter who the hell
you are coming up and smacking a
comedian because they made a joke what
are your thoughts on what happened with
will smith and chris rock well i think
it's a it's a big amalgamation of things
first of all it's like a representation
of what's going on in society you know
like everybody's on on edge we're all
full of [ __ ] all the time and the more
full of [ __ ] you are it's kind of like a
relationship
if you don't talk about everything and
communicate it just bubbles up and then
eventually you hit a lady you know
and that's kind of what's happened here
like these guys will smith is a
zillionaire he's hugely famous and he's
scared of his wife as we all are i think
we should change the name from karen to
jada but
great bit but yeah i just think we're
all going through a lot hollywood's full
of [ __ ] all they do is talk about being
activists and stopping assault and down
with hate and helping people and coming
together and then they see a guy
literally
attack someone physically in front of
them and they don't do [ __ ] about it
because somebody had a great point
hollywood doesn't act they react so they
wait to see how the societal wind is
blowing and then they go in and go well
this is what we think like oh you only
think that because that's the right
thing to thank you [ __ ] queefs
are you saying that hollywood ain't real
yes and it's all like
celebrities are having a bad couple
years we used to look up to celebrities
they were huge endorsements now
with the pandemic all these imagined
videos with the black and white and
we're hurting and i feel for you and i
need to work on shut the [ __ ] up you all
live in a [ __ ] mansion in malibu
you're completely out of touch you just
say the things you're supposed to say
you don't give a [ __ ] about people you
only care about yourself which is fine
that's great we're all selfish but don't
pretend like you do
and after he slapped chris rock
everybody consoled will and nobody gave
a [ __ ] about the guy got hit that's how
far off we are off base in this goddamn
society so [ __ ] will he made a mistake
jada's terrifying she's [ __ ]
uh her son's friend yeah which is also
weird imagine imagine a guy did that hey
i'm [ __ ] my daughter's friend
whatever yeah they make a movie about it
called american beauty yeah exactly
exactly where's kevin spacey yeah
exactly has it done anything
inappropriate lately but let me ask you
this all right i got worked up let me
ask you this because i want to get your
thoughts on jada female empowerment and
uh she's sort of like the face of
feminism these days
but
um is she really because because she
really uh she's all about i'm a modern
woman but yet i want my man to be
traditional and and protect me so which
one is it
are you traditional well yes i agree but
my question to you is we're kind of
[ __ ] on hollywood and rightfully so
bro sure but isn't chris rock hollywood
he is but he's still a comedian he's a
he's a real guy at the end of the day
more so than will smith i think but he's
definitely a famous comedian yeah can't
deny that and this is something that i
talked about on our other pocket pb
podcast with pat i go people forget
before kevin hart
before chappelle chris rock was the
freaking man
he was the guy yeah he was the guy in
the 90s what was this better than both
of them by the way really as a comedian
oh yeah oh yeah well i was going off on
this whole thing with the trends and
everything and like a freedom fighter
which is great do your thing but rock
kept it funny the whole time the whole
time and kevin hart is is on a chase
commercial and doing jumanji eight yes
so i think rock just was like i'm gonna
keep being a comedian yeah well chris
rock's acting not as good as his con no
well that's that's that's i mean i don't
wanna be controversial here and i like
how you sometimes sign off
from your your comedy you say all right
i've been uh kevin hart and thank you
what do you say i'm kevin hart thanks a
lot i only say that because i used to
bomb a lot and i didn't want to tell
them my real name
kevin hart [ __ ] you um speaking of
bombing a lot uh is that your transition
it was good um but amber you're you're a
comedian i am um
you deal with some you know as a female
i want to get your perspective on what
happened with jada and if your man would
have stood up for you i want to get that
perspective but also being a female
comedian or just a comedian general what
kind of [ __ ] do you have to deal with
hecklers whatever
oh i mean just the first conversation
always is like you're a comedian right
and you're like why do i look like a
dentist like i don't know
what i should look like but there's
watching this had lots of from different
perspectives the comedian perspective
the human perspective the female
perspective i think as a human where we
watch all these robots like like this
watching will have like a moment where
he like broke through
his his like facade was cool to watch it
wasn't that it was it was empathetic to
watch and i think a lot of people if
they side with him they're not realizing
that it was wrong they just like liked
seeing something very real and like
yeah visceral it was just like raw and
that was i think what was exciting about
it not that they actually side with him
obviously all the like the women are
like oh my ovaries hurt that was so hot
like he oh you so this was a turn on for
women is what you're saying i i've heard
a lot of that perspective you see a man
be like
so up in arms about i mean yeah we've
all seen him we all saw him laugh and
then look at her and then change
so it was like in that moment his own
feeling didn't matter as much as him
seeing her be offended so that kind of
emotional consideration for your partner
is admirable how do you just sat there
and maybe done this part i agreed that
would have been really cool because
that's like hey i'm angry but i'm
reserving my
my physical anger because what that was
a long walk okay there was nothing i
mean he walked like cool as hell he's
like swagged out and then so there was a
lot of thought
pre-meditative you know i always say if
he was in the fifth row that wouldn't
have been as effective he had to shimmy
through
excuse me for a second yeah
from a female's perspective what was the
biggest turn on meaning him looking at
his girl seeing that she was offended
and emotionally reacting a
b getting up there walking up and
slapping no the scene the
the yelling keep my [ __ ] wife
name out your mouth that whole what was
the biggest turn on for the female
listen i feel like as women a lot of
times we get [ __ ] on for overreacting
and a lot of times you get gaslighted
like hey that's not offensive like calm
down so like just to see your husband
your partner acknowledge that emotion
that maybe he didn't agree with that's
the thing is being a partner being
empathetic hey i don't feel this way but
seeing that it affects you makes it real
so i'm gonna react that part i guess it
was attractive but the walk over and the
hit
unhinged that was not good no i don't
find men fighting attractive at all
tears we talked about this tears
emotional vulnerability that's that's
right we did should a man cry
wait wait wait one last thing yes the
whole this whole
scenario i just think the funniest part
about it is like it's obviously a whole
team of writers who are coming to the
table with this joke i mean chris rock
definitely has his input but a bunch of
people signed off on that and they
probably were like okay guys we can't
make a joke about the relationship so
let's pick something less offensive and
they went with gi jane and then this is
not that complic like i i guess he
she he didn't know she had alopecia or
whatever it's not that controversial of
a joke well i don't have anything you've
actually made a documentary on women and
black women in their hair yes good so
it's not like first rock has yeah
so if he was another guy who had less
emotional um sensitivity towards the
subject maybe it would have been like
it's still it was all around not a great
combination of things but it was a turn
on that he actually defended his woman
you really want to keep going yeah
i want to remark what was the biggest
turn for you
that's what i really want to get to i
think the fact that chris rock just took
it like i would have been like what the
hell
i would have totally bitched out so and
look we do this whole we really reward
victimhood in this culture like all
these non-victims are acting like
victims like will smith cries at the end
he gets the oscar he's like i want to
protect everybody it's like shut the
[ __ ] up you big douche get out of here
you now you're culturally appropriating
victims there's real victims out there
so what about that but were you were you
ever a will smith fan or were you sure
i'm just saying i don't like the way
this was handled i think he's going
through a lot i think he's in a mental
spiral i think he's [ __ ] up and i
think he's mad at his wife and mad at
the situation and he and it took it out
on chris also poor quest love
yes
yeah what happened with chris this was
his moment and it's gone because he won
the award yeah he's a [ __ ] great guy
literally the most i don't even know
will smith made it about him anyway
movie summer of soul check it out we we
addressed the will smith chris rock
situation can we just say thank god this
is black on black sir you know if this
was uh ben affleck who went up and
slapped chris rock this would be a bad
time to be a comedian
i don't know if i've ever heard thank
god this was black on black
i don't know if i've ever heard that
yeah well yes i agree thank god this was
it wasn't also once again white people
did nothing
yeah we stood by yeah we might have
called the cops that's true
[Music]
you